bonsoir polir oeil merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france alors vous
avez un veau confirmé l'étude publiée
dans la revue zealand 7 sur l'efficacité
de ce vaccin russe une étude réputé
objective indépendante comment at elle
été menée pour bien qu'on comprenne de
vacciner sa routine treiber et dynamique
au japon en titre et habituées à la gare
utilise un vecteur du virus qui a déjà
été utilisée par astrazeneca et par
johnson & johnson et par un vaccin
chinois russes et un vecteur très
accommodante dans les vaccins
beaucoup d'études ont été menées sur le
sujet les blacks c'est sans surprise que
sjp accents 55 qui crie soit très
efficace car il utilise une approche
légèrement différente avec eux de ça des
navires est ce différent
ce qui veut dire que l'immunité de la
première dose ne faiblit pas celle de la
seconde les autres vaccins à vecteur
admirer ce nom utilisé qu'un seul par
exemple l'adénovirus un coup là de
nombreuses femmes 6,5 pique-niques fait
utilise les deux virus protein spike
poutine
c'est ça le virus sont porteurs du gène
de
la lipoprotéine de pointe qui permet à
l'organisme de se protéger contre
l'infection l'adénovirus introduit dans
l'organisme ne peut pas se répliquer et
se contente de produire les protéines
qui sont ensuite enregistrées par le
système immunitaire qui lance une
production
brotchi sceau de la prochaine fois que
le virus arrivé pour contaminer et bien
ces protéines sont complètement bloqués
après deux doses le taux de protection
et de 91 6% à trahir de vacciner des
lois il faut placer 12 milles des
leaders de vaccination lors des essais
étaient des trois pour un ailier
plusieurs milliers de personnes dans ses
essais et il y à eut pas d'effets
secondaires dont c'était pas des faits
assez content à crabes donc c'est un
très bon vaccin
donc effectivement 86 % d'efficacité ça
le place parmi les vaccins les plus
efficaces sur le marché
efficacité sur toutes les catégories
population ya subi que ce dernier
oui ils ont étudié tous les niveaux
d'âge à partir de 18h jusqu'à 60 à plus
de 60 ans et des hommes et des femmes il
n'y avait pas de différence au niveau de
la protection entre les différents âges
donc c'est un vaccin très performant et
je pense que la raison pour cela c'est
qu'ils ont utilisé deux types d'aidé ne
serait pas un seul
c'est ce qui fait sans doute la
différence
bien sûr il a beaucoup à dire sur ses
vaccins mais ils ont été désactivés sont
pas vraiment des adénovirus simplement
des vecteurs pour permettre à
l'organisme de produire des anticorps et
l'immunité
ces lymphocytes t est également très
efficace car cela est produit à
l'intérieur des cellules
c'est un très bon vaccin bref c'est un
vaccin très performant très efficace
comparé aux électrodes autres vaccins à
des virus
alors c'est nouvelles sont plutôt très
encourageante et pourtant il ya eu
beaucoup de méfiance
on s'en souvient en août dernier quand
la russie a annoncé avoir trouvé ce
vaccin et qu'elle allait le produire
vous partagiez ce sentiment comment vous
expliquer cette grande méfiance que
beaucoup ont eu à ce moment là new delhi
dow est déplacée depuis cause des actus
les vacciner dit saint pie xii qui c'est
la façon dont le vaccin était présenté
ils ont ils commencé à vacciner des gens
en première ligne avant d'avoir terminé
les essais de france 3 dans les pays
occidentaux on ne fait jamais cela à
l'époque elle ou 600 personnes avaient
été vaccinées et pas de tous les âges
mais même à l'époque le taux
d'efficacité était élevé cependant on ne
met donc pas cela car de plus les
données n'étaient pas claires cela
manquait de transparence
nous pensions qu'il faisait prenez des
raccourcis car il n'était pas aussi
ridicule qu'on peut l'être dans les pays
occidentaux mais maintenant cette
affaire est réglée car l'étude publiée
dans le lancet que la semaine dernière
cette semaine montre qu'ils ont bien
suivi toutes les règles tout les
règlements
nécessaires afin de prouver l'efficacité
du vaccin
ce vaccin est tout à fait au même niveau
que les autres
l'irak produit dans un temps record un
ou dernier très rapide quand on sait que
plusieurs vaccins évidemment mettre des
années alors c'est vrai que c'est le cas
aussi d'autres vaccins mais enfin quand
même il ya quelques mois d'écart comment
expliquer cette rapidité chez nos amis
russes
bill cosby provost les leaders
politiques réactions sont sans doute
plus prend les décisions beaucoup plus
rapidement
de toutes les nations leur système
régulatoire réglementaire différent des
règles différentes
à suivre et sans doute qu'en russie ils
ont pu aller plus vite de ce point de
vue il faut comprendre que et virus les
vaccins a pas de nouveau reçu ce n'est
rien de nouveau
astrazeneca on a développé en chine
c'était 15 au local
il est possible d'avoir un vaccin sans
aucun danger à vecteur du virus donc en
russie ils ont pu s'appuyer sur ces
résultats et a avancé beaucoup plus
rapidement
necessary ils ont suivi toutes les
étapes nécessaires pour le développement
d'un vaccin
donc je pense que cette rapidité était
dû à la réactivité des organes
régulateurs
il voulait aller vite et donc ils sont
mis en place un système accéléré
fast retailing ce week-end si nous
promettant que je sache le vaccin ne
pousse pourtant aucun problème c'est un
bon vaccin est peut-être que cette
rapidité pouvait être perçu comme
inquiétante début lorsqu'ils ont publié
les résultats des essais de phase 1 et 2
sont assez d'informations mais la
troisième phase la plus importante c'est
et les données sont très très très
suffisante c'est une dernière question
avant d'être produit et distribué en
europe il faudra obtenir dans cette
fameuse validation de l'agencé
européenne des médicaments combien de
temps pourrait-elle prendre selon vos
goûts
je ne peux pas répondre à cette question
je ne sais pas je ne suis qu'une
scientifique qui est donc je peux dire
ce qui est un bon vaccin ou un mauvais
vaccin mais je pense que cela pourrait
être très rapide car les données sont
très solides et je ne pense pas que cela
posera problème mais je ne pourrais pas
vous dire quand cela sera fait à deux
reprises mais il y a déjà des
négociations avec d'autres pays par
exemple avec l'amérique du sud donc je
ne le serai pas surprise iolo bst aussi
l'europe adopté rapidement ce vaccin
également il n'y aurait qu'une récente
contre cela un vaccin c'est un vaccin
s'il est efficace c'est l'important et
nous avons besoin d'un très bon vaccin
si rapidement possible le passeur
titulaire d'une chaire de virologie à
l'école dit j
n et de médecine tropicale de londres
merci à vous